two million dollars raised so far for
marine lieutenant colonel stuart sheller
to help who was thrown in the military
jail for posting a video on social media
slamming the biden administration's
bosch afghanistan withdrawal take a
listen
if an 05 battalion commander has uh the
simplest live fire incident eo complaint
boom fired but we have a secretary of
defense that testified to congress in
may that the afghan national security
force could withstand the taliban
advance we have chairmans of joint chief
who the command is a member of that
who's supposed to advise on military
policy
we have a marine
combatant commander
all of these people are supposed to
advise and i'm not saying we've got to
be in the
in afghanistan forever but i am saying
did any of you throw your rank on the
table and say hey it's a bad idea to
evacuate bagram airfield the strategic
air barriers before we evacuate everyone
you know the money raised by the pipe
hitter foundation will go towards
possible loss of military benefits and
retire and retiring in the mounting
legal costs on top of other expenses
ever since sheller was thrown in the
brig his parents have gone public to
talk about their son
our son
we're very proud of our son our son is a
hero
he fought for this country for 17 years
they left hundreds of americans in
afghanistan
where they're leaving our son tonight in
prison
and that's not okay with us and
i challenge the american people is that
okay with you we want stuart
sheller released we would like him to
have his pension reinstated his
hard-earned pension we would like him to
have his medical benefits that he is
going to need after the deployments that
he has endured but if they won't do that
at least release him and let him out of
the marines
you know it's just it's heartbreaking to
hear that and a letter from gop
lawmakers to the marine commander on
chelsea this confinement appears to be
simply for messaging retribution and
convenience
given his excellent record in more than
15 years of dedicated service we do not
believe and have not seen any evidence
that the lieutenant colonel shelter
poses a grave risk of criminal
misconduct
you know
it's just
you try to you you try to put your head
around this and it just doesn't make
sense you're attacking i get it
insubordination but wouldn't that be
just a
a
talking to why do you think and i'm
going to go to you first of this uh sean
why do you think it's so important to
quiet anyone who questions this
administration
because you can't have dissent tyrus
right and i'm going to read you a quote
from the marines the marines said uh
this is a marine official who said they
consider sheller a flight risk and
believe china may intend to use his
comments as propaganda remember back
tyrus earlier this year in alaska when
blinken met with the chinese and the
chinese were using biden and democrat
comments as propaganda to call americans
racists
they know all too well about propaganda
in this story what really frustrates me
is sheller was someone who stood up and
said if i lead if i put my rank on the
table i'm going to inspire other people
to step in and put their rank on the
table and call out this botched
withdrawal from afghanistan no other
officer stood up and that's the problem
in america we all look at brave people
who will stand up and and risk
everything to push back on these vote
politics but if we don't stand with them
if we don't join the fight don't join
the cause we're going to lose to the
woke leftists more people have to get in
the fight and it's shameful that more
military men and women didn't join his
call to go this listen i i get ranked
but we can't have this in our military
and someone should lose our jobs someone
else should be in jail not
me all right well let me take you some
new sound from sheller we can roll that
i was the only officer in the entire
american coalition fired in the debacle
of afghanistan fallout
i acknowledge that i should have been
fired
however the hypocrisy of the general
officers who are not being held to the
same standard is a microcosm for the
entire problem that is going to bring
down the great institutions of this
republic that we love
jackie i get you can see one side of it
you know there you know he shouldn't
speak out of rank but in terms of
messaging do you really have a problem
with what he's saying oh absolutely not
what i have a problem with is the fact
that he's the only one getting fired
look at the administration and this
botched withdrawal why doesn't anthony
blinken have any responsibility here he
should lose his job what about kamala
harris she was the last person in the
room when the decisions were made and
what about the president being
accountable for what happened leaving
americans on the ground abandoning
afghan partners who helped us while we
were there you know this is really a
problem back to what sean is saying this
is the administration to a certain
degree turning us into the ccp turning
us into russia controlling the messaging
and basically showing people you will be
punished if you speak out what i'm
really proud to see here is the pipe
hitter foundation eddie gallagher he
went through a whole trial and saga
himself he knows how much money it costs
he knows that it can destroy your life
so 27 000 donors other vets from this
country other countries as well have
stepped up to say we're going to help
here we're going to make sure that you
have enough money for your benefits for
your legal defense for the pension that
you're walking away from this is really
sad and we have to fight for our freedom
of speech in this country and he's doing
that
you know and and i i saved you for last
lisa because i know it it's coming it's
coming can you believe they said with a
straight face they were concerned that
he would flee to china and they would
use his statements as propaganda as if
they don't have cnn in china i i just i
give it to you
yeah he did the one thing you can't do
which is speak up against the regime i
mean go through the things you're
allowed to do you're allowed to get 13
service members killed due to your
incompetency that's okay you're allowed
to drone an entire family including
seven children lie about it that's okay
you're mark milli you're allowed to
attempt a coup that's okay but you can't
speak out against the regime and
jackie's right we have communism is
taking hold in america we've seen it
throughout the past couple of years with
cove it's not just with this either it's
destroying small businesses and
companies that are more decentralized
while empowering the centralized which
are these big corporations it's paying
people to stay home and to get them
beholden to the government it's the
vaccine mandates of driving independent
thinkers critical thinkers out of the
military and out of the workforce and
all of it what all of it does is to beat
people into submission and to destroy
those who dare not submit and that is
lieutenant colonel sheller so that's why
it is so important for us to fight back
and thankfully people are donating and
standing up and we have members of
congress standing up as well because
this is a fight not just for him but for
all of us
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilmeade and
i'm ainsley earhardt and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis